Hello, this is the Lee Detective Agency. We
will take on any request.If
necessary, we will carry your luggage.If necessary,
we will do our best to arbitrate the dispute.We will do our best to solve the dispute
.  Investigations are an
exception, but that's the job of the police, are
n't you too much like a detective drama
?  Hey
, I told you not to grab it with your bare hands
Don't get caught Don't get caught
Phosphorus 15 prohibited Shrimp fundraiser Please give me something fresh
Didn't you say you were going somewhere?
Uncle, please go home and
lock the door. Where
did he go
?  Are you sure about that The cat world is right in
front of us
[music]
I've been watching them all day but
no one has come out So who the hell
were they?
Please refrain from
chartering
[Music]
Do you think it
will work?
I didn't mean to come here
Oh,
[music] I
found
you, drop me off Just
now is for my friend
[music]
Are you okay?
You
're a strange old
man who hires a lot of people
to go to the theater with his daughter.
Do you have any worries
?
Chat and play together  Is
it
true? That's an
unexpected answer.Do you want a
friend?
Money is only temporary.Are you in such a tight financial situation
?
You can't buy it,
okay, man, so
you can make an inheritance
[music]
[applause]